[Music]
you did a a show about [ __ ] now
what do you mean you did a show about
[ __ ]
there is an art form
to being [ __ ]
and we honest so one of our producers
put up a plug and said if you think
you're a [ __ ] not somebody else thinks
you that you think you are these are
people who think themselves
then we'd like to hear from you
thousands of letters unbelievable people
think this is the way to go through life
it works for me so these are people who
uh would tell you
i'm a [ __ ] and they're proud of it
proud of it and and they haven't you
know people like that
uh yes i have yeah let's leave it at
that would you like to no no i i'm
kidding i would like to give us some
names no no no no no no uh i i don't i
don't think i know anybody like that
but um
but there are yes i think there are
people who uh might be women who think
it's a kind of a strength you think
that's why they do things to strength
and it works for them you know they get
paid off for it and so they just keep
doing it they're just kind of adult
bullies that go around
just
dogging on people all the time and it
works for them so they do it i see it in
a lot of reality shows that's where i
see it there's a lot of reality shows
where people are really proud of the
fact that they lost their temper
and and pulled someone's hair and kicked
him out a window do you think people
really think that's reality the reality
do you think they think realities don't
have writers and scripts and say okay
now on the count of three you turn the
desk over or don't ruin this for me i
love those shows
y'all don't think that's real do you i
think p i think a lot of people yeah
okay never sure now they don't yeah
you just ruined it yeah why ten seconds
ago they did yeah they just came from
the set of beverly hills housewives so
where where are you all on the easter
bunny i mean it's
do you know that's not real if i burst
your bubble here yeah you sort of have
yeah i love those shows i hate that for
you uh i'm curious about something else
uh you you broke out and i was shocked
to see this but on your show you broke
out your dance moves with your wife
and uh not a bad dancer i'll say that
no i'm a horrible dancer you're a
horrible dancer yeah
you remember naven from the jerk
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yes
that's great but steve martin yeah they
i was invited to do dancing with the
stars and before i could say no my wife
said that ain't happening
and i thought well she's just trying to
protect me because she knows i would
make a fool out of myself she said no
i've been watching those girls and none
of those girls going to wrap those legs
around you for any reason what's what
she was serious about that she watches
him like on tomorrow's show we have
donny osmond on the show
and he won it last season and he was
talking about they what do they call
argentine tango or something they do on
there this is like a sexy dance he said
his house they called that you sleep on
the couch dance uh because they get a
little touchy-feely don't you my god you
yes you watch those dances and the women
are half naked half the time and they
get all wrapped up around the guy and
it's insanity it is
never miss it
so that's why you can't do it that's why
you're not allowed to be on that show no
she said no way no how would you would
you be allowed to do that sure yeah yeah
yeah
very open marriage i'm allowed to can
you dance because all i ever see you do
is spin around i dance i'm an amazing
i've got a very fluid and sensual body
can you show us a move here we're going
to do i'm not going to dance
[Applause]
come on on the dash we want to see a
move
use every erection to its fullest
potential
[Applause]
now see
that's actually something andy's upset
that's actually
yes he's gonna have to explain that with
puppets later
that was actually pretty fl you were
actually moving pretty well what do you
mean actually moving pretty well i
didn't think i started as a dancer well
you're built so high off the sidewalk i
thought maybe you wouldn't be tall and
lean like tommy tune i got it going on
uh like tommy tune
[Laughter]
show won't air we're not airing this one
i'll give you a copy and andy can have a
copy but we won't air it